Aaron Rodgers just stop fine higher good
see you yeah I don't know yeah it's Dan
it's here
it's a Paulie and Seaton and fritzy and
McLovin yeah I don't know if McLovin had
it was yeah well he come on yesterday
for Alex Smith and then Alex Smith lit
him up and then got traded soon after
yeah so I might get traded to if that
was wild though yesterday what did you
when you heard that that Alex Smith had
been traded like what do you think well
I wasn't really surprised only because
when you draft a guy that high at some
point you got to put him in I was always
surprised in that he played so well this
year that I thought I might give him
another year but it's a Pro Bowl season
job well he kind of got another job yeah
for more money yeah and more guaranteed
money so I'm not I'm happy for him I
think he's been underrated his entire
career I really do
well he said that there were times he
wishes he would have been number one
overall pick wish you wouldn't yeah you
wouldn't trade with me well would it
have changed how would that have changed
you do you think like when are you ready
for that being the number one pick and
everything that goes along with it
because then he'd said I'm labeled a
bust
where's you got a little bit of time I
don't know how you call him a bust what
he did we're going into our 14th year
yeah a lot of people said after that oh
five draft oh the guys in oh six would
have all gone in front of Alex and Aaron
well we're still playing
yeah we're in our 14th season and we've
started the majority of him I'm going to
my 11th year he started you know damn
near every year as well so I'm proud of
him I think he's a great guy he's a
friend of mine and I'm happy for him it
feels good to be wanted I'm sure for him
yeah and he's unfortunately got through
a couple times now where San Fran they
you know see somewhere else and now
Kansas City you know hey thanks for the
you know the run yeah got some nice
parting gifts for you but I tell you
what the Redskins their fans are I think
they're ready to put some stuff together
and they need some help they're probably
but
you get the right piece in place a
quarterback now and and there's not any
gray area with the Kirk situation so
good form how the Viking fans treat you
they're not not the nicest but what do
they say to you I haven't heard a whole
lot of stuff yet but there's some boos
this morning and one of it okay which is
great but don't you have to be at a
certain level to get a boo like yeah no
I think so if you're terrible cheering
you yeah like we want to keep you in
there quarterback yeah we used to our
fans would cheer for other backup
quarterbacks in from other teams but
they don't say anything like how's this
feeling the backdrop we have here is the
stadium that was it you know you like
that place I don't think they should
have put the windows in there it's like
Dallas you have this these shadows why
do they do that at least put detect yeah
what's the toughest stadium to play in I
think Seattle based on noise see I don't
Kansas City are the two loudest
environments but then you're talking
about something different with Dallas
and here where you're getting a glare at
certain times yeah the two-minute drive
we had in Dallas there was a second down
play I'm doing this right here I'm
trying to see where John leaves a degree
of difficulty yeah we've had a couple of
quarterbacks on Alex Smith we've heard
the Commissioner they still can't come
up with what to catch why is it that
Alex Smith said I don't know what a
catch is been in this league this long
you know this we've added surviving the
ground like why do we keep adding things
instead of taking away things we're out
the technology the technology makes the
ability to rewind those plays and slow
them down to frame by frame where you
can see oh the ball moved like five
millimeters so it's you know not
entirely a catch the one that we hear a
lot when it's referred to catch we've
been apart a couple questionable catch
plays of the Phil Mary for one which was
the interception obviously and then the
the Dez Bryant play yes was a catch
which Dallas fans want to say was a
catch it was not by the rules no but
here's my problem
Dez Bryant makes the catch and he makes
an athletic move
so what we're saying is don't be
athletic what happened with Jesse James
in the Pittsburgh and game against New
England is it's an Endicott that up on
it yeah we did we we thought it okay
that's a catch that I thought what I
think this is a catch what I think a way
to do it could be is if you catch the
ball inbounds and a go out of bounds
doesn't matter what happens after that I
agree right because you already had a
bounce who care so why should you have
to take the ball all the way to the
ground
this right here such a bizarre plot okay
catch and then to me that's a fumble in
the in the pittsburgh game against New
England
what would you say that that's a fair
assessment well I mean it's it's
completing the kids yeah no stop with
the completing the cat it's the rule he
caught it went to the ground lost it on
the ground and then recovered a fumble
for a touchdown I don't know I don't
understand where the goal line doesn't
come into play on that one
yes catch knee down goal line then that
might might change it but nothing after
that right now the goal line could
change it and the and the side line
could change it or anything after that
you secure the ball and feel to play
yeah right but I don't know just see you
don't even know no I know you can said
definitively what it should be I know
what I know what it is so we agree that
Dez Bryant that was a catch
Jessie J no you already won the game
it's okay don't work yeah you can just
label do to catch play someone we just
said there's no goal line
can you say I want you to can you stay
for others yeah okay we have Aaron
Rodgers draft profile that you get to
read there's some good stuff in here
February
backdrop the home field Minnesota
Vikings of course the site of Super Bowl
52 and expecting 70,000 fans in that
building Aaron Rodgers has been in that
building he's now in our building across
the street
you have good memories of that building
no yeah glad I could bring it up yeah is
it is it weird though that building that
you know is it sometimes too big you get
these stadiums that a little cavernous
whereas Lambeau is more intimate there
no you know I don't think that one feels
too big Dallas is a monstrosity but then
they have that the Jumbotron actually
makes it feel a little smaller because
you're always doing this even you even
you you're doing that oh yeah will you
come off after a third down you want to
look up but what happened I'd say it was
Stadium is beautiful in us it's got the
Super Bowl next year is Atlanta yeah I
mean what they did to the top of that
stadium the architecture is phenomenal
and I'll be a fun city I think to the
plan where can you hear the hecklers the
best well in the division probably
anybody make you laugh Oh 100% yeah I
mean there's so ridiculous that what
they really want is your attention
it's want your attention yeah so there
start with some derogatory stuff but
then it goes to just ridiculous
off-the-wall stuff anything to get you
to turn around or laugh or thumb up
what's the strangest thing though you
acknowledge where you turn around you go
okay I got to give you credit there well
it's Philly when I was about Philly when
I was back up the easter they were
yelling at me hey Rogers get the
splinters out your ass
this guy was yelling at all game
long its 2007 and Monday night game and
so finally after literally a quarter and
a half him do it I find terrorize again
I got you man that's kid he got me and
that was it then did he stop yeah if you
stop then he started yelling Tedford
[Music]
tedford makes an appearance yeah okay
what does that mean okay they study or
buy okay I got your draft profile you
excited about reading this yeah Mike Joe
got all the good stuff
why well oh the good the actual good
stuff not the good bad stuff yeah okay
so this is just bad stuff good alright
so you get to read it thank you
we've popcorn Ernest going down other
miss me by the way drew brees read his a
couple years ago yeah and he said can I
keep this motivation okay
this is actual comments made by Scouts
draft profile Aaron Rogers gets sacked a
lot doesn't have ability to change the
release of the football mechanically
very rigid he's a little too short Jeff
Tedford coach quarterbacks never pan out
too well schooled very robotic
don't become good pro players Rogers the
same old system quarterback who can't
create on his own l CH panics under
pressure gets flustered easily well what
bothers you the most from that profile a
lot of it I just know it's more than the
funnier things are too well schooled
like you can be too prepared is that a
bad thing I guess a very robotic
now paulie's got the names of all the
people who said these things are you
interested in one in particular and Paul
II can give you the name of the scout
it's probably all unnamed people holding
you got names attached to this I'm gonna
write them up you can put them in your
pocket protecting sources I need some
more motivation do you manufacture
motivation hey you have to do a little
bit I think but it it it changes I think
after a while from kind of that chip on
your shoulder to prove everybody wrong
too
challenge yourself to to play at a high
level every year which is a hell of a
challenge the older you get by the way
here and just put that draft profile in
his pocket that's letting people know
yeah yeah I could do put that in your
locker now maybe know that yeah yeah
check it out if I go into your house can
I do I know you're a football player how
long does it take before I know what you
do for a living well if you go in the in
the office or the bar probably there's
some there's some gear there yeah I got
some some memorabilia I haven't thrown
in the closet jerseys yeah like some
opposing player jerseys
our team doesn't really like it but a
few jerseys swap oh like soccer yeah
yeah but you know other teams always do
it you check Instagram it's like the you
know guys have played at the same school
together or you know former teammates
with us it's like don't do any of that
just you can get fined actually I think
for doing some of that like kangaroo
court there with the Packers where you
know like Packers take money out of your
check for oh they will for holding on
new jersey or trading it
who's the Jersey that you have that I
might be surprised any sport
yeah although I worried on my Instagram
I'm gonna be surprised about Zaza
Pachulia I love given size because of
the name I also have a Drew Gooden
Jersey of course yeah everybody does
yeah everybody does those are my guys
have you been approached to be on Game
of Thrones I can't confirm or deny that
I like that I like that and did you ask
if you could be killed if they did ask
you to be on game yes I definitely want
to be killed her and one of the steamy
scenes for Steve yeah I think you might
get killed first yeah I probably killed
yeah nudity would you do nudity partial
depends on be naked yeah probably
then they're never naked anyway there's
always you know socks and different
things
but you're willing no you're not willing
not I'm willing to be naked so much I
know you're uh I know you're with
Marriott what are you doing with
Marriott yes I'm hanging out on behalf
of their their loyalty programs how's
that microphone treat yes it's been
great sorry about that but may I ask the
goatman they got they got two hotels all
over the world man but what they do cool
is for their Rewards members day yeah
they do some cool VIP experiences
they've done create different stuff over
the years whether it's hanging out with
super chefs or first pitch of the World
Series to their members who accrue the
most points this one is probably the
lamer than that but it's a VIP
experience with me tomorrow night we're
doing a cool intimate hangout they've
done some other stuff this week as well
get to watch the game so it's it's oh
you're staying through the game I'm not
but I'm trading out somebody else to
watch the game with them but I'm doing
it I'm hosting a party tomorrow night
for there they're 12 top members and a
guest it's it's great I mean they've
been they've been fantastic and for
anybody with any interest in that
Marriott coms we find out some cool
other VIP experiences we'll see you at
Pebble coming up next
I can't wait yeah you're playing at
Pebble I am me and Jerry Kelly team
Scotty I like that I like that all right
before you leave we've had the
quarterbacks Moreno Alex Smith they've
thrown a couple passes to McLovin
McLovin has gloves on we prepared a
football for you would you could you
light it up a little bit
yeah I line it up okay cuz I don't know
yeah I've only thrown the three
footballs yesterday since since you guys
remember but I'll be alright
okay I know and are you 100% now yeah I
feel good okay all right we're gonna
find out McLovin stand up by the way
case keenum brought a jersey for mclovin
[Laughter]
how does that impact you're gonna throw
the football at McLovin he's got a
Vikings jersey on here you got to get a
helmet on McLovin get your helmet I
really need a helmet well I don't do you
trust Aaron that he's gonna
get you right where he needs to hit you
all right here we go
thank you it's been quite a week for
McLovin dan Marino threw a couple balls
Alex Smith Case Keenum now there you go
what do you want me to run
he's your Jordy Nelson here yeah yeah
yeah okay why don't you do sir
get your head around quick we're doing
okay yeah we're doing - okay all right
here we go all right into Clement all
right oh boy oh that was the easy one I
had no idea that was there could someone
help me out a little bit well why don't
you just stand there so you don't run
into the pole all right wait
[Applause]
how did Aaron how does anybody catch
that oh yeah see the window there word
hit all right here we go did not hit the
ground he survived the ground well done
I'll see you next week
let's see Aaron Rodgers Sanderson join
us coming up next
I think McLovin got roughed up just a
little bit there with his hand for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]